docis biden trying to make a big
comeback even with terrible poll numbers
after a week of resting up at the beach
in delaware the president finally thinks
he has the wind at his back he's gearing
up for a victory tour of the country to
tout some legislative wins and his white
house chief of staff ron clean is
already out there with the trash talk
i don't think it's true he's out there
less than his predecessors
i just think
donald trump created an expectation of a
president creating a storm every single
day
and that led to a cycle
of cable news coverage and twitter and
so on and so forth
and uh i understand that made people in
your line of work you know very busy and
very productive
the media ramping up the biden height
machine new york times is trying to make
the pro-biden dark brandon meme a thing
with this headline quote dark brandon
rises and buoys biden's beleaguered
faithful
the times also claiming aviator joe is
back arguing the president shades are an
emblem of his continued vigor and check
out these lap dogs
this big thing on dale that is a big
deal this is huge and i don't think
people understand how big this is this
has been an extraordinarily
successful uh two years legislatively
big victory at the white house yeah it's
such a big win for president biden he's
actually interrupting his vacation and
flying back to the white house today
just for this bill signing
tyrus
listen i don't know what you would know
about things like using props to to
present yourself
to have a persona to create an air about
you a perception but um you know you've
shown that can work outside of the ring
but i don't know that biden's going to
make aviators work outside the movie
here's the thing either you got the
charisma
or charisma as we say in the biz to
where you can wear a cardigan and have
someone tell you it looks like a
sweatshirt and still be all right you
either have it or you don't and with all
due respect mr president
the brother don't he doesn't have it so
i don't care how you dress it up
glasses dark brandon whatever he's still
shaking hands with ghosts and doing all
kinds of weird stuff and to say he has
wins with what's going on right now is
just unbelievable there is enough
chinese fentanyl in this country
literally a stat i was reading today to
kill americans seven times over our
border crisis is unbelievable
our inflation people looking around he
has spent more five total of five months
so far outside of the office which is
the most the last three presidents so
to say he's present to say he's doing
things he's stopping his vacation to
come back because this is the first
positive
thing he's had to where they have to
come back for him to do the bill signing
if he was doing
so well he wouldn't have to stop and be
like hey look what i did check me out
put my glasses on and whatnot because
his poll numbers the only good poll
numbers he has will that judge bring
that to you they're not even good
they're just the best he can have this
dude this this entire administration
they know
americans sick of it so they're trying
to act like they got one thing out of
50. congratulations that's still
horrible numbers you know katie when he
first brought the aviators back and i'm
not saying anything disparaging here i
thought it was because he was still sick
and i felt like because he gave that
speech while he was while he was
suffering from covet and i thought you
know i get it you might look dark in the
eyes from being sick let's do this but
uh emily campagno made a really good
statement we don't wear sunglasses in
our business because we need to be able
to see
the viewer needs to see our eyes that's
how you communicate he's just putting a
wall up between him and the viewer it's
almost like maybe that's part of why he
can't tell what's happening in america
well joe biden is still deeply unpopular
when it comes to his poll numbers and
i'm sure jessica will argue that her
full numbers are going up in the past
couple weeks but he's still deeply
unpopular conveniently the white house
has hid him away back away from the
press during the one-year anniversary of
the afghanistan withdrawal which was a
total catastrophe joe biden's riding his
bike on the beach while democratic
mayors are berating republicans for
sending illegal immigrants to sanctuary
cities they should be having phone calls
with joe biden about that problem but
the best place for joe biden to be
really is away from the cameras and away
from giving any kind of statements
because when he does his press shop then
has to clean it up making him look like
he's not credible
and if he's really going to have a
comeback you'd think you would see a
number of democrats who are running for
election or re-election on the campaign
trail in the senate and the house
inviting him to come campaign for him
but instead they're running as far away
as possible from joe biden including in
ohio and you also have a number of
democrats refusing to say whether he
should run again in 2024 including
senator whitehouse just today so
you know joe biden's poll numbers go up
when he's away from the media um but in
terms of successes and answering
questions and being transparent about
what's going on they're happy to keep
them away from the reporters you know
judge i guess the media is working
really hard to make it look like joe
biden is just having such a legislative
windfall right now it does the chips act
in this new new green new deal does that
make up for what happened in afghanistan
a year ago does that make up for what's
happening at the border i mean i get you
know maybe democrats didn't think trump
could tout tax cuts as a legislative
victory i don't think republicans and
independents see these as as the big
legislative wins democrats say they are
i don't know any american is running
around saying thank god joe biden got
these legislative wins look first of all
the legislative wins that they talk
about like the inflation reduction act
we know that's a lie this i think the
congressional budget office is saying
they're not calling it that anymore
they're working at the green new deal
now climate change well but the truth is
that that's what it's billed as that's
how they passed the bill they've lied to
us and all of america knows that that
was a lie and the truth is that this
president and this administration are
doing everything they can to pursue
their own agenda and not the agenda of
the american people and tyrus is right
this president has taken
150
150 vacation days that is five months
off in a year and six or seven months
that is crazy he is not capable of ron
claim complaining and saying you know
that donald trump yeah you know every
day there was an s storm that donald
trump came out yeah there was you know
why because he was doing things and the
left was going crazy because they
objected to it and in the end what
you've got are the democrats going crazy
every time donald trump did something
and the democrats at this point are
saying we've got to build joe up even
though half of us don't want him to run
again even though most of us don't think
the guy is capable of finishing a
thought or a sentence because it's
important to us so that we can win you
know jessica it's a good point he's been
on vacation i mean he got elected from
the basement so maybe he can get
reelected on vacation maybe there's a
strategy there but uh is this biden's
win is this biden's victory or is this
chuck schumer's victories
it's democrats victories and that's the
decision that people make katie's not
wrong biden is personally unpopular he's
been inching up he's now around 40
popularity but the democrats as a party
as the choice of americans heading into
the midterms are getting increasingly
popular now it's tied in terms of who's
favored to win uh to take to be in
charge of congress were favored to win
the senate um mitch mcconnell was caught
yesterday you know by a reporter asked
about what he thought was gonna happen
and he said that they're not likely to
take back the senate a few months ago
mitch mcconnell felt pretty good about
those odds in terms of who's actually
happy about those legislative wins just
an example diabetics people who use
insulin for instance whip clyburn shared
a story about his now past wife emily
who took insulin she paid twelve hundred
dollars a month for her doses this will
be down to 35 a month because of the
fact that now medicare can negotiate
drug prices do you know that part of the
inflation rate much of that 700 billion
is going to go to just that just curious
like you know how much of it
i know that senior citizens in this
country should we be okay to spend that
much money to get one thing it's not one
it's not only one thing that's good i'm
a type one diabetic at home and i have
not seen an inch of any of this talking
about and the last thing our doctor told
us
and it's going to take a lot of
loopholes i'm just saying
it's unfair to reduce a thing that is
unequivocally a good thing to just oh
it's one good thing there are a bunch of
good things in there and just because
it's not your politics doesn't mean that
it doesn't count this is and if you look
at that energy no information
it's about saving people's lives it's
making sure that they have health care
oh yes health care saves people's lives
when history looks back at the first two
years of the biden term they will see
the american rescue act they will see
bipartisan infrastructure the pact act
the chips act the inflation reduction
act they will see that al-zarahiri is
dead they will see record jobs numbers
they will see low unemployment and i'm
not saying that they will say joe biden
was god's gift to the presidency but do
not reduce what has been accomplished in
this term and democrats got that done
with the slimmest of majorities well if
democrats are trying to sever themselves
from radical progressives someone needs
to let joe biden know about that hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else